bien un jour bonjour à toutes et tous
monsieur mettling bonjour merci de nous
avoir rejoints dans le cadre de cette
audition pour notre mission
d'information sur le thème de l'ubs et
risation de la société cas l'impact des
plateformes numériques sur les métiers
et l'emploi
je crois que vous avez été alors vous
êtes vous a été chargé par le ministère
du travail de coordonner une mission sur
l'emploi des travailleurs des
plateformes numériques donc vous êtes la
première personne que notre rapporteur a
souhaité auditionner et je lui laisse je
vous laisse la parole ou je ne sais pas
s'il veut intervenir un instant
peut-être vous poser des questions
voilà chers collègues
est ce que peut-être je dis ça c'est ma
ma collègue martin verte et de savoie et
moi sénateur du val demain c'est notre
première expérience comme martin bartek
comme présidente et moi comment à porter
je le disais state comme nos positions
sont plus présentes et vous la
présentation était très bien fait mais
la vôtre encore plus parfaite
présentez-vous qui après six à avoir je
vais vous questionnez sur l'objet de la
mission
allez-y monsieur notre côté
et moi bien goûter merci d'avoir de
votre accueil je suis très honoré de
cette invitation dans le cadre de vos
travaux que je crois sincèrement
important alors celui que vous avez
choisi d'interroger j'aime bien me
définir quand même praticien y social et
pas comme quelqu'un qui aurait
évidemment étudié d'un point de vue
macroéconomique d'un point de vue le
sujet voilà celui que vous invitez c'est
quelqu'un qui observe ce phénomène
d'impact du numérique sur le travail
j'aime bien la produire de cette façon
là j'observe depuis quelques années à la
fois comme quand l'occasion j'allais
dire de la mission que j'avais conduite
il ya déjà cinq ans maintenant c'est
françois rebsamen qui m'avait demandé de
conduire la première réflexion au niveau
national parce que j'avais été le voir
en lui disant monsieur le ministre c'est
un peu un paradoxe est trop souvent
l'observateur parce que j'ai été dans
une vie professionnelle serviteur de
l'état avant de donner un parcours plus
privé à mon parcours personnel et
j'avais très souvent frappés du fait que
quand des grandes transformations sont à
l'oeuvre trop souvent l'état un temps de
retard notamment en matière sociale et
donc gilles avait à l'époque été voir
françois rebsamen en lui disant mais
j'aimerais bien pouvoir conduire et
coordonnée la première réflexion où l'on
croisera le point de vue des partenaires
sociaux du medef à la cgt pour résumer
au niveau national j'entends avec des
experts du numérique pour qu'on puisse
voir si cinq ans il ya cinq ans
maintenant se dégage c'est vraiment de
tendance et ce travail alors même que je
l'avais remis à myriam et de conneries
ce travail avait été conclue de manière
consensuelle
si vous vous rappelez le contexte
n'était pas évident au moment dé des
lois dites telle connerie de faire
converger et du medef à la cgt sur une
transformation du travail et c'était
tout simplement autour d'une méthode que
l'on avait défini dans cette commission
quand une fois le rapport porte mon nom
mais la réalité c'est que c'est un
travail collectif et yang à lire ici
c'est que d'une part on sentait bien que
les partenaires sociaux confronté à
cette transformation numérique avait le
souci de construire ensemble certain
nombre d'outils libres et pas forcément
de partir se distendent une page
nouvelle de la projection des analyses
que des uns et les autres pouvaient
avoir sur les équilibres économiques
donc à volonté de définir un nouvel
équilibre et d'autre part de cet
équilibre était née une espèce de
posture que je crois toujours
pertinentes qui consiste à dire face à
l'impact du numérique sur le travail
face à la question qui nous est
aujourd'hui il faut pointer avec la même
exigence les formidables opportunités
que comporte cette transformation mais
aussi les risques tout aussi important
donc là des porteuses et qu'il faut
pointer avec la même exigence et 7
cet équilibre cet état d'esprit qui
avait permis encore une fois de conclure
de manière consensuelle dans un moment
difficile
je me permets de rappeler parce que
encore une fois c'est un travail
collectif qui avait été extrêmement
continent et qui se situe aujourd'hui
dans une nouvelle étape
à l'époque par exemple on avait pointé
la nécessité du droit à la déconnexion
et ce droit des connexions avaient été
repris dans la loi de conneries dans la
foulée de ces de ces travaux je donne
cet élément là parce qu on pointait déjà
s'agissant du télétravail du travail
n'existe alors je fais ce détour parce
que évidemment de 7m vie professionnelle
qui voyait le drh que j'étais croisés en
tout cas observateur quel animateur de
débats sociaux croiser un petit peu
cette résidence à 120 sur numérique
j'ai poursuivi démentant que drh
d'orange je me permets de rappeler pour
présenter que j'ai été le drh et de la
crise sociale d'orange et c'est vrai que
ça a été un moment important que
d'apaiser cette entreprise qui est un
des grands acteurs du numérique et je me
permets de rappeler également c'est le
premier employeur du numérique en france
on a tendance à projeter uniquement dans
l'univers de la nouvelle économie mais
il ya aussi évidemment en france des
acteurs industriels importants sont
confrontés à cette consommation
numérique et enfin plus récemment encore
une fois j'ai créé une structure qui a
dédié justement d'accompagnement de
cette transformation
et c'est dans ce cadre là que la
ministre du travail mme a bien voulu il
demandé de coordonner l'encore dans une
démarche collégiale à une task force sur
justement comment répondre à ce
formidable défi et c'est ma manière
d'introduire le sujet s'il est bien dans
la présidente monsieur le rapporteur
c'est de dire à la fois on voit bien que
ces plateformes ont permis l'accès à
l'emploi d'environ chiffre est à
débattre
l'accès à une activité d'environ cent
mille personnes en france et c'est pas
négligeable
ils sont deux personnes qui pour des
raisons diverses mais était en réalité
souvent exclues du marché du travail
donc ça c'est l'aspect opportunités et
en même temps s'agissant de ces livreurs
dix ans de chauffeur vtc en particulier
des livreurs
ils sont victimes d'un déficit de droit
et de protection que je qualifie de tout
aussi inacceptable dans ce système
social européen
dans un système social comme donc là
encore on voit bien cette dialectique si
je peux me permettre
il consiste à dire comment garder la
dynamique dans cette nouvelle économique
peut-être porteuse dans un certain
nombre de cas est en même temps pointé
avec la même exigence
ce déficit de droit et c'est dans ce
cadre là qu'on a fait c'est ce travail
qui a consisté en s'appuyant sur toute
une série de rapports qui avait déjà été
fait dans le rapport soins de grande
qualité je ne parle de le dire parce que
on a pu conclure très vite et faire un
tour de piste et écrire c'est au projet
d'ordonnancé pour le gouvernement de
manière rapide par ce qui est
précisément s'est appuyé sur toutes les
séries d' expertise qu'il y avait en
amont mais quand on regarde un petit peu
ce que la concertation a permis de
définir c'est un petit peu ça c'est de
dire on est arrivés séparément ce qui
dans une logique consistant à dire il ya
le débat sur le statut salarié ou par ge
ne reviendra si vous le souhaitez gma
profit de son personnel en tout cas la
feuille de route qui était la nôtre et
celle de cette mission consistait à dire
est-ce que nonobstant la problématique
du débat sur ce les salariés ou pas on
peut dans le cadre de la négociation
collective progresser rapidement sur les
droits et protection de ces travailleurs
des plateformes de manière à répondre à
une situation assez inacceptable parce
que je le dis avec la même conviction
quand c'est sur l'opportunité quand on
regarde les problématiques de temps de
repos quand on regarde les
problématiques de revenu minimum quand
on regarde les revues de transparence
quand un accès à l'information les
concernant on voit bien qu'on est de
fait dans une logique j'allais dire qui
n'est pas respectueuse d'un certain
nombre de droits sociaux fondamentaux au
niveau européen et qu'on peut qualifier
comme tels
donc on a fait cette concertation je
propose ne pas être forcément beaucoup
plus longue dans ce qui était une
introduction médard fou qui est la
mienne ont dû aller un peu plus loin
qu'une introduction pour vous dire que
la conviction qui est la mienne
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il ya bien sûr ce
débat et encore une fois c'est un débat
important chacun il ya ces conditions
est en tout cas en ce qui concerne la
task force
vous avez pu observer qu on a sorti cet
projet d'ordonnancé sur les conditions
dans lesquelles pour pouvoir avoir un
dialogue social il faut déjà désigné des
représentants légitimes n'existe pas
aujourd'hui et que ce processus là et
cette ordonnance là dans un secteur qui
est très sensible socialement je crois
qu'on peut aussi le dire vous avez pu
observer cette ordonnance a été prise a
été publié sans susciter de protestation
sociale particulière c'est parce qu'en
amont encore une fois il y avait une
concertation assez large et on a essayé
de définir des équilibres
y compris quant à la responsabilité de
l'état dans l'émergence de ce dialogue
social s'agissant de nouvelles modalités
de structuration d'un dialogue social la
responsabilité qui était la sienne pour
accompagner sa dédire l'émergence de ce
dialogue social qui doit être beaucoup
plus équilibré que 200 les choses
aujourd'hui c'est un des enjeux
donc on pas en revenir de manière plus
détaillée mais le fond du message
aujourd'hui c'est de dire que ce débat
légitime sur le l'accès au statut de
salarié ou pas nos cultes et pas l'autre
question très importante sur comment
aller vite vers des droits et protection
de ces travailleurs qu'ils optent pour
le statut de salarié ou pas ou que le
juge requalifie pense qu'on ne peut pas
y revenir si vous le souhaitez mais en
tout cas dans ce qui est sans doute
aujourd'hui le plus grand déficit en
terme social de modèle social de notre
pays il faut aller vite permettent les
négociations 200 planches et à des
droits nouveaux d'être octroyée dans le
cadre d'un vrai dialogue social qui
suppose évidemment un minimum
d'équilibré dans la négociation entre
les parties s'est il passé
première étape par la désignation de
représentants légitimes pour représenter
les intérêts de tout le processus que
vous connaissez de l'ordonance des
élections voilà j'étais un petit peu
long d'un moment la production pardonnez
moi mais c'était pour que nous soyons
rapidement dans le coeur des échanges
très bien je vous remercie
chers collègues rapporteur est ce que
vous avez des questions oui la
présidente et est ensuite pardon et
ensuite nous passerons la parole à nos
collègues qui suivent cette audition
avec qui nous avons l'honneur
oui merci je vais thing présentation
fougueuse mais à périmètres la loi et
vous dire que cette mission son intitulé
notre travail d'investigation donc les
questions je vais me permettre de vous
poser et puis éventuellement celles
d'autres collègues va toucher d'abord
qu'est ce qu'on appelle libéralisation
de la société et demandera sa joue 10
une question qui va qui va traverser
d'autres auditions des tables rondes ou
alors la besoin d'explorer cette
question-là peut pas
seulement la traiter de manière par trop
générales ou globale et les autres
aspects c'est l'impact et des
plateformes de travail ont certes à la
fois et numérique et le travail steps
les deux cohabitent et nous y
reviendrons sur les métiers l'emploi
puisque j'ai écouté votre présentation
avec beaucoup d'attention
vous avez bien formuler les choses il
faut nous dire et ce qui relève de
l'activité escalade de l'emploi et vous
savez bien que c'est de terre n'ont pas
la même signification
donc sur ce que vous avez appelé
l'opportunité dans l'accès et en même
temps vous avez souhaité mettre en avant
le fait qu'il ya un dialogue social et
une protection sociale de bonne tenue
je demanderai à mes collègues de ne pas
commenter l'aspect ordonnance nous
sommes dans une phase nationale
il ya eu tellement de ordonnance que des
fois le parlement s'est sentie j'irai
dire lui pas tout à fait bien placé de
ce point de vue là mais je vous demande
qu'on ne met pas ça dans le débat pas
parce que ça m'intéresse pas mais parce
que je pense que ce n'est pas le sujet
voilà mais comme il y avait fait état
alors dans mes questions une vient tout
de suite là aidez nous à avoir
quels sont les principaux secteurs de
l'activité économique concerné tout le
monde le sait ici il ya les livres a les
chauffeurs mais je crois que tout le
monde a compris qu'il y avait d'autres
secteurs de l'activité économique qui
sont concernés donc essayer de nous
éclairer de pas votre expérience
pourquoi je dis ça parce que l'
ordonnance que vous avez cités n'a
touché que deux secteurs so lu ment et
donc là pourquoi ou pas ce vide
pourquoi cette absence pourquoi voilà ça
ça nous intéresse
troisième chose dans quelle mesure des
secteurs économiques
ib risée sont marqués par ce qu'on
appelle la polarisation entre travail à
forte à cette valeur ajoutée ça
intéresse autant les travailleurs
d'ailleurs eux aussi notre tissu
artisanal commerçants des p o
c'est une question qui revient souvent
chez nos concitoyens étant en exercice
de responsables d'entrepreneurs
sur les quais on sait les conséquences
de libéralisation j'avais que j'ai pu
prendre connaissance et apprécier les
éléments ou avait listé dans votre
rapport de 2015 relatif à la
transformation numérique au travail le
lieu de travail
on sait quand ça le temps de travail de
la rémunération
chacun met d'ailleurs cicc qui veut mais
c'est des questions quand même très
terre à terre mais posez la fonction man
and managerial aidé rapport à la
hiérarchie
alors là sûrement apprendre beaucoup de
choses sur la qualité de vie et la santé
au travail donne un petit écart vous le
savez tous en belgique par exemple c'est
là un des pays où il ya eu des allers
retours entre salariat pas salariat
salariat passe à l'arrière pour une
raison très simple c'est des aspects
d'accidentologie des livreurs c'est ça
qui a fait bouger la question du statut
est par exemple
bon donc c'est un élément sûrement que
nous avions gardé nous il faut aussi
qu'on garde ça les mobilités des
reconversions reconversion
professionnelle et donc quelles
nouvelles évolutions législatives ou
réglementaires les deux ans ce qu'il
faut s'autoriser à tous ici vous
paraissent prioritaires en termes de
droit du travail et aussi aux droits à
la sécurité sociale questions que vous
avez évoqué sur les enjeux de la
négociation collective
vous avez évoqué moi j'avais été dix
youn et par la mission froid elle a eu
deux évolutions à vous me dîtes si je me
trompe pas il ya la voix un moment la
question du dialogue social était posée
après ne la question du statut après on
est revenue au dialogue social
ce qui pour ce fonds était pas ça parce
que c'est pas toujours facile pour le
périmètre de la mission
interministérielle évolué mais si j'ai
bien compris voilà où on en est de ce
point de vue là selon aux travaux
d'investigation je crois que j'ai évoqué
aussi donc c'est cette question qui est
lancinante d'évoquer dans le rapport
d'introduction de la mission que j'ai
ouvert tout à l'heure vraiment il faut
qu'on regarde quels sont les métiers les
secteurs concernés autre que les
livreurs des chauffeurs et puis si vous
pouviez et on va se demander aussi à
d'autres essayer d'avoir un travail
d'anticipation dire que l'élu que je
suis j'ai regardé des offres à pôle
emploi j'ai vu que l'équipe première
mais ouvertes étaient souvent des offres
non qualifiés
mais qu'ils restaient non couvertes donc
ça à vrai sujet quand même parce qu'elle
suscite
elle évoque un besoin et un besoin
d'activité c'est fois un besoin de
profession ils ne sont pas ouvertes
alors on a un taux de chômage assez
important donc je pense que ça c'est un
questionnement qui peut intéresser ceux
qui nous ce qu'ils nous écoutent et
l'ensemble des sénatrices et sénateurs
une autre question je m'excuse de toutes
ces questions mais bon et certaines se
recoupent et puis vous les traitez avec
votre expérience
question qu'on peut se poser des
organisations syndicales tradition
traditionnelle ou en sont-elles sur
secteur des sur ces secteurs d'économie
touchées par les prises à sion nous
avoue je pense qu'on a un peu de
références de ce point de vue là il ya
des actions je les ai vus mais qu'est-ce
qui se passe est ce que vous pensez
qu'il ya des évolutions initiatives
supplémentaires sur la question du
dialogue social gélules ordonnance sur
la question de la représentation
nationale et ce qu'on sait sur les
bottes échéance est ce que le jem pas
dire ça mais ce que le public concerné
et adhère totalement à cette ce
cheminement de représentation nationale
la question franchement on prend l'avoir
rencontré pas assez mais pas mal de dos
est libre de ses chauffeurs joie que
c'est la question n'est pas si simple
de ce point de vue là comment vous voyez
les évolutions de la commission
européenne où la gelée que l'époque est
tout à l'heure on voit bien qu'à je le
dis il ya eu des lutins des
démobilisations quand même assez forte
il ya eu des actes juridiques ont pesé
je pense en espagne ans en angleterre
voilà dans plusieurs pays européens en
italie aussi - coupe du chili un peu la
donne au niveau européen donc qu'est ce
que vous attendez ou de ce point de vue
là cette échelle h et elle l'a sur le le
droit de la représentation collective
d'aider des travailleurs et puis alors
sujets il y en a pas c'est le dernier
excusez-moi de cette liste un peu à la
prévert mais alors là c'est un vrai
sujet aussi c'est la question de la
place graux
l'algorithme est là ça nous interroge
tous tout à l'heure je disais à nos
collègues nous disait nous parlait d' y
compris l'utilisation dans la fonction
des task pour les chaises on le vit avec
parcours sud par exemple pour qu'on nous
écoute
voilà qu'est ce que vous en pensez la de
cette entrée pour ma part je pense qu'il
faut réguler et c'est une prise de parti
mais je pense qu'il faut la réguler faut
pas seulement demandé qu'elles soient
transparentes
comment la réguler parce que elle l'est
complètement l'outil de subordination et
c'est pas une mise en relation
c'est un outil de subordination
j'ai fini ma la presse un chien chers
collègues voilà chers collègues on va
peut-être lycée monsieur mais répondant
continuera par d'autres d'autres
questions ensuite c'est vrai que le
champ est très large effectivement nous
avons un temps limité pour faire cette
réaliser cette mission d'information
puisque nous devons frein septembre ont
présenté avoir terminé ce rapport le
sujet effectivement du ver isation de
l'état dont on vient de parler notre
rapporteur est un sujet très large et
qui méritera très certainement d'être
traité lui-même à part entière je ne
suis pas certaine que nous nous ayons le
temps de le traiter dans le cadre de
cette mission temps en temps les sujets
sont larges et en celui ci
particulièrement voilà donc je vous
laisse répondre si vous voulez bien à
ses premières questions merci merci
beaucoup sont très riches sur le coeur
du sujet et je vais donc essayer de
voilà de d'apporter quelques éléments et
encore une fois votre réflexion
permettra d'éclairer mais sachez que la
difficulté que l'on a c'est qu'on est un
sujet en cours de construction et que
par exemple dans le cadre de la mission
quand on projetait simplement le nombre
de plateformes qu'il fallait anticiper
le nombre de travailleurs de ces
plateformes susceptibles de voter
ce sujet là d'une semaine à l'autre si
ces petites d'évolution très importante
je le dis parce que la grande difficulté
est compris du monde de la
représentation nationale à travers le
cadre d'initiatives et réglementaires
c'est que ça évolue tellement rapidement
que j'avais dire la capacité à suivre en
termes d'encadrement législatif et
réglementaire cette activité est déjà en
soi un énorme défi des familles dans cet
algorithme c'est bien évident que le
croisement entre ses algorithmes leur
puissance et les principes auxquels on
est tous attachés s'agissant par exemple
du droit social n'est pas seulement du
droit à la protection des données autres
éléments tout ça évidemment est un sujet
redoutable et périlleux et pourtant il
nous faut l'adresser alors si je survole
un petit peu quelques éléments quand on
me demande de résumer l'impact de la
transformation numérique sur la
situation des salariés en général j'ai
coutume de rappeler encore une fois dans
cette vision pratique oprah que j'essaye
d'amener à ces échanges d'un contrat de
travail comporte quatre mentions
obligatoires
c'est à dire ce qui est au coeur de la
relation entre un salarié et
l'entreprise
la première chose qu'il fait quand il
arrive dans une entreprise ou qu'un
jeune access des salariés ici un groupe
de travail vous avez quatre mentions
obligatoires
vous avez la rémunération vous avez la
référence au plan de travail vous aviez
le lieu de travail et vous avez sous
l'autorité de qui vous travaillerez
monsieur untel quand je regarde l'impact
du numérique vous apercevez que trois de
ses quatre mentions sont complètement
bouleversé par ces nouvelles façons de
travailler
la rémunération quand elle n'est pas
n'est pas directement modifiées même
s'il a des conséquences
on voit bien que dans les modes projet
les modes agit qui caractérise une
nouvelle façon de travailler en
entreprise
la référence un chef précis n'est plus
pertinente on voit bien que le lieu
déterminé devient un concept de plus en
plus j'avais dire est consacré par
l'actrice prend des véhicules et
travaillent de plus en plus pertinents
et puis la référence un temps de travail
et c'est un sujet permettez un ancien
drh de le dire extrêmement sensible dans
l'entreprise déséquilibre de temps de
travail sont évidemment profondément
bouleversés je le dis parce que le sujet
que l'on prête est important mais
s'inscrit plus globalement je crois
qu'il faut le dire dans la
transformation ni millery du travail et
emporte y compris pour les salariés y
compris pour les fonctionnaires des
conséquences extrêmement importante et
là encore pointons les opportunités
qu'il ya avec les risques avec la même
exigence
le deuxième
le deuxième élément évidemment sur
pourquoi se concentrer dans votre dans
le projet de texte veut dire
d'ordonnancement pas suscité de débat
auquel je leur ai une contribution que
très modeste pourquoi dans ce projet de
texte c'est de concentrer sur les
livreurs et les vtc pas sur les autres
je crois qu'il ya deux réalités derrière
deux faits derrière qui sont très
importants le premier élément c'est
qu'on est sans doute en termes de
déficit de protection quand on voit ce
genre particulier des livreurs sur ce
qu'il ya pu y avoir de plus graves dans
une fiction d'indépendance allez dire
des travailleurs est une situation de
dépendance économique absolument
considérable et une situation sociale
hassine acceptable et moi je trouve sain
de commencer à s'attaquer pour un sujet
concernant le doigt par les situations
qui heurte le plus je crois notre
conscience collective par rapport à
l'attachement un système social et
protection sociale système social
européen je t'aime tu m'aimes
d'européens et de droit qui sont
attachées ou 4 je crois on accorde tous
une grande importance et donc commencer
par la situation la plus dégradée ou la
plus problématique est sans doute façon
pertinente d'adressé de sujet mais je
vois une deuxième raison qui est
peut-être encore plus important pour les
équilibres que vous avez définies dans
vos questions à monsieur le rapporteur
et qui est que incontestablement les vtc
et les livreurs
on a vu la nouvelle économie la nouvelle
économie dite numérique et technologique
les plateformes numériques développer
des marchés qui n'existaient pas
autrement dit l'impact je revenais sur
les taxis dans un instant s'il veut bien
mais l'impact par rapport à une économie
traditionnelle pré existant est
caractérisée par statique salariés est
assez limité personne ne peut contester
que les livreurs envie là il faut
développer par l'arrivée de ces
plateformes est décédé ces outils là est
le vtc est venu compléter une offre on
va dire des taxis artisanale meti
comment dirais-je si je suis mesuré dans
mon propos je me dois d'être aujourd'hui
avait grand besoin d'un peu de renouveau
pour assurer le service et on voit bien
que derrière ces plates formes btc
l'offre des taxis c'est d'ailleurs
moderniser et adapter et on est sorti
d'une situation qui te parle beaucoup de
l'aspect faisait des qualifiés notre
pays quand dans la condition d'accueil
et de mobilité en zone urbaine donc on
voit bien qu'on est sur deux secteurs
qui ne venaient pas gaufres ont affronté
la nouvelle économie
et là où je vous rejoins c'est que
développer sur ces domaines là des
nouveaux équilibres les nouveaux droits
ne pas faire forcément du statut de
salarié
la condition sinequanone les
développements de droit et sans doute
perdre
non mais qu à l inverse et je le dis en
tant que responsable de la task force
les concertations que j'ai mené les
écoutes que j'ai pu faire me font penser
que passer les conditions de la
négociation collective et des nouveaux
droits sur ces deux secteurs là à
l'ensemble des aides de services à la
personne des aides aux entreprises et
généraliser cette pratique ne
comporterait de mon point de vue des
risques bien plus important parce que
c'est vrai que quand on va être sur
l'intérêt quand on parle de services à
la personne quand on parle de services
aux entreprises
quand on va être sur l'intérim quand on
va dire sur d'autres domaines on vient
déstabiliser
je le dis tranquillement dans des
conditions économiques qui sont pas
commandés l'âge d'un point de vue de la
concurrence comparable des secteurs
préexistant qui emploie des milliers de
salariés et donc moi je suis de ceux qui
disent était pertinente de commencer par
ces deux secteurs pour les raisons que
j'ai évoquées mais soyons prudents à ne
pas généraliser au nom des progrès qu'on
va sans doute réalisé dans ces deux
secteurs moyennant sa femme de condition
en se disant tout de suite les
conditions sont remplies pour une
généralisation j'allais dire de ce mode
d'organisation sur les secteurs des
services à la personne et des services
aux entreprises qui sont les nouveaux
enjeux
c'est à dire de développement de ses
services nina alors voilà pourquoi
c'était réponse à la question sur
pourquoi céder secteur par rapport aux
autres parce que d'abord il y avait un
déficit de droit qui justifiait d' agir
rapidement dans ce domaine là mais je
crois que la deuxième raison c'est qu'on
s'y attaque tf2 secteur qui était quand
même assez nouveau qui n'ont pas
j'allais dire frontalement bouleversée
comme ça peut être le cas sur l'intérim
des secteurs j'allais dire emplois peu
qualifiés et valeur ajoutée limitée mais
qui sont extrêmement sensibles en volume
d'emploi et en activité qu'ils peuvent
représente donc je crois que le prochain
débat c'est j'allais dire à travers
l'intérim notamment mais entre
particuliers services à la personne les
services aux entreprises
sur ce point je voudrais quitter entre
guillemets les mandats officielle qui
m'ont été confiées sur ces sujets pour
vous faire part des convictions du
citoyen que je suis de l'homme a eu un
certain nombre d'engagements dans sa vie
professionnelle vous avez compris que
voilà et d'observateurs du dac sociale
je considère que deux éléments que vous
les partagez qui sont pas qu'ils sont
pas assez souvent rappelés et qui
figurait dans le rapport que j'ai remis
au ministre il ya cinq ans ce qui est
inconcevable et qui est le vrai problème
est un préalable de mon point de vue est
l'extension de ce mode d'organisation à
d'autres secteurs c'est l'absence de
contributions financières sont pas des
termes un dessin au financement de notre
système de protection sociale de santé
il est pour mon on ne peut pas se
féliciter d'avoir ce niveau de droit de
protection dans nos il s'agit de santé
qu'il s'agisse de chômage qu'il s'agisse
pour la famille etc et donc un niveau de
contribution économique apportée par les
acteurs et en particulier par les
entreprises
on veut pas se féliciter de l'existence
de systèmes dont bénéficient d'ailleurs
c'est à dire en place un stand
travailleurs indépendants et ne pas
poser la question de la contribution des
plateformes au financement de ce secteur
je pense que le jour où je ne fais pas
que des amis en disant ça mais je l
assume
le jour où on a défini des modalités de
cotisation de contribution à parler
comme ça parce que cotisations renvoie
le journal des modalités de contribution
au financement de ce système là par ses
acteurs économiques qui emploient de
plus en plus de travailleurs
on aura sans doute plus progressé y
compris dans la perception d'une
concurrence déloyale qu'à juste titre un
certain nombre d acteurs peuvent évoquer
quand on parle d'étendre ce système là
d'autres domaines et donc j'ai une
conviction que j'avais il ya cinq ans
que je continue à porter et dans la
concertation récente on a bien vu que
des représentants des entreprises au
sens medef du terme au sens de
représentants des petites et moyennes
entreprises non sens de représentants
des professions libérales que ses
associations ses organes et son
professeur était sans doute encore plus
virulente
quand on risque d'une extension que des
organisations syndicales traditionnelles
donc je le dis ici pour moi il ya là il
ya un enjeu alors c'est un jeu
évidemment ils se heurtaient aussi à du
droit européen envoyé jeu je survole un
peu vos questions mais tout ça est un
enchaînement qu'on peut très bien voir
là la cohérence globale le cadre global
europe disait jusqu'à présent si vous
menez une négociation sociale dans cette
dans ce secteur-là si par exemple toutes
les entreprises de livres à l'issue
d'une des valeurs sociales des
entreprises qui rend wauquiez emploi des
livreurs conviennent d'un prix minimum
de la course
eh bien elles ont elles font une entente
au droit de la concurrence
le sacro saint droit de la concurrence
s'oppose à ce que ceux des plateformes
qui sont en concurrence puisse convenir
à l'issue d'un dialogue social de
l'accord collectif et 2
donc rapport à libye entre guillemets ou
restreint des plateformes nous exprimer
très clairement et donc on a mission que
encore une fois nous avons conduite pour
la ministre il avait deux bornes
nous avons interrogé l'europe et en
particulier l'autorité de la concurrence
sur le thème est ce que vous pensez
qu'il est normal acceptable par l'ape
association des libraires et donc on a
senti je voudrais profiter de cette
présence pour comment dirais-je remet de
la dynamique dans cette question que les
autorités de la concurrence nous ont
clairement dit non
la situation aujourd'hui devenue
intenable qualifiée d' entente le
résultat d'un accord social entre des
livreurs leurs représentants et les
plateformes et évidemment même pour les
représentants du droit de la concurrence
pardonner à quelqu'un qui sait beaucoup
bagarré sur la vision de la concurrence
européennes de le dire même du point de
vue des autorités de la concurrence
c'était quelque chose qui était perçu
comme inacceptable aujourd'hui donc un
projet de directive un projet de
directive est en cours il est prêt les
autorités bruxellois ne nous ont pas
caché comptait beaucoup sur la
présidence française pour porter cette
directive me demandiez en quoi il ya des
travaux qui sont nécessaires il est
indispensable de porter cette directive
est de la faire aboutir dans le cadre de
la présidence française parce qu'il faut
une certaine sensibilité pour porter ce
sujet parce que ces directives que
dit-elle en collectif d'un statut de
salarié ou qu'ils aient le statut
d'indépendant des accords collectifs
signé entre les représentants de ces
travailleurs et des plateformes ne
peuvent pas être qualifiées d' entendre
si vous n'avez pas ça si on raisonne
toujours sous cette menace là on risque
de ne pas pouvoir progresser rapidement
sur les droits nouveaux donc c'est pas
un premier élément je souhaite
absolument livre il faut réveiller ça de
la même façon je le dis en passant je le
dis en passant de la même façon que l'
ordonnance ne comporte que la moitié du
chemin
elle permet pour faire court de désigner
les représentants par arie les
représentants pendant des travailleurs
des plateformes de désigner ses
représentants
elle permet deuxièmement de créer
l'autorité des relations sociales des
travailleurs de plates formes d'emploi
qui va accompagner la mise en place de
ce nouveau diallo sociable et j'en
profite pour mentionner comme a bien
voulu me demander à une suite à ces
premiers travaux puisque je suis chargé
de la mission de préfiguration de cette
future autorité
et c'est pour moi un point important
parce qu'encore une fois pour réussir
ces montants par neil fausse émission
mais il manque toutes les thématiques de
dialogue social
il manque toutes les thématiques de
désignation de lait place des
représentants des patrons eux mêmes
bref la moitié du chemin a été fait mais
si on veut tenir le calendrier exigeant
que le gouvernement a annoncé que je
soutiens totalement dans la mesure où
derrière il ya des attentes de la part
d'un certain nombre de travailleurs qui
sont importantes il faut évidemment un
dispositif législatif très rapidement
nous permettra évidemment un dialogue de
s'organiser y compris quant aux effets
d'un accord et dans tout ça d'un
d'intérêt notamment ce qu'on appelle le
dialogue au niveau des secteurs qui
permettrait pour tous livreurs ou pour
tout chauffeur vtc dès lors qu'un accord
est intervenu de se voir appliquer un
espèce de socle de droits de protection
de manière généralisée qui ne serait pas
laissée à la bonne volonté des
plateformes de signer si on veut faire
ça il faut que ce complément législatif
trouve une place dans un calendrier que
je sais par ailleurs près serré c'est
votre contrôle pour être abordée très
rapidement et pour permettre de
calendrier que nous avions en tête au
niveau 2 dans la concertation nous avons
fait qu'ils aient désignation des
représentants des travaillant au premier
semestre de l'année prochaine
négociation dialogue social les premiers
résultats au second semestre ce qui du
point de vue de la situation des livres
et des chauffeur vtc et déjà croyez moi
très lointain rapport aux attentes
qu'ils ont donc je veux j'en profitais
pour compléter ma réponse aucun type de
dispositif at on besoin pour être
opérationnel donc derrière il ya toute
une série de décrets que je vous ai pas
dit ce qui est important pour moi c'est
qu'un complément ni pour moi pardon pour
tous ceux qui font ce travail c'est qui
est complètement législatives qui
puissent qu'ils puissent retrouver
rapidement sa place alors sur la
question de la position des oreilles
sans syndicats traditionnels et je lui
permet de le dire du salariat de la
mission et sans prétendre trancher ce
débat ô combien sensible
j'aimerais simplement vous donnez à
votre mission quelques repères qui
doivent fonder le moment venu une
réflexion qui en elle-même en tant que
tel justifierait que l'on s'y penche
le système de salariés en europe quand
on compare menée par évidemment homogène
et la france se caractérise et cet
heureux du point de vue qui est le mien
par un niveau de droits et d'obligations
associé à ce statut salarié est assez
exigeant et pour les deux parties
qu'il s'agisse de loyauté en entreprise
qu'il s'agisse de temps de travail qu'il
s'agisse voyant passer en revue tout ce
niveau de droits et d'obligations
quand vous donnez le statut n'ont pas de
salarié d'ailleurs de cdi comme on
pourrait le penser mais de voir que en
grande bretagne au chauffeur vous leur
donnez certes un certain nombre de
protections complémentaires ils sont
utiles mais quelque part je vous
rappelle qu'un contrat de worker peut
comporter zéro heure de temps de travail
imaginons en france par rapport à la
place que le temps de travail à dans le
contrat de travail des contrats de
travail donc on voit bien que la réponse
apportée en termes de salariat selon les
différents pays d'europe ne peut être
projeté sans conséquence sur un modèle
comme le nôtre j'ai beaucoup insisté
dans des échanges avec les partenaires
sociaux nous engagions syndicales qui
sont de plus en plus consciente que
derrière la généralisation comme ça du
satis à l'art y est au travail il y
aurait sans doute à terme pour le moins
questionnés en déséquilibre recherche de
nouveaux aménagements du statut de
salarié pour mieux répondre à des
contraintes d'activité qui sans cesse de
ses travailleurs et donc d'une certaine
façon je me perds de lire risques de
fragilisations ou du gué risation du
salarié et donc la conviction qui est la
mienne et là je m'excuse vraiment à
titre personnel c'est pour la situation
de 600 milles en tout cas d'autres plus
de ceux qui peuvent venir derrière
réfléchissons bien à double alternative
qui est statut de salarié mais qui
inéluctablement de mon point de vue
conduire à des aménagements des
flexibilités des adaptations du statut
salarié qui peuvent être assez
importante ou octroi de droit à une
protection pas négociation collective
avec des accords évidemment qui
s'imposeront qui s'imposeront un
ensemble de partis c'est évidemment vous
l'avez compris la manière dont on aborde
le sujet plutôt la seconde option qui à
l'autre avantage d'être assez rapide
être plus rapide mais qui n'enlève rien
au rôle de tous ceux qui à travers des
décisions de justice à travers des
actions collectives utilise le levier de
la requalification pour faire progresser
la situation des droits et des
protections de la grande conviction à
moi c'est que dans un système français
avec ce niveau de droits et
d'obligations associé au statut de
salarié c'est heureux ce déficit de
protection dont sont victimes ces
travailleurs là je pense avec beaucoup
de conviction ou l'incompris qui
faut pousser la voie de la négociation
collective productrice d'accord
collectif sous le contrôle de l'état je
le dis avec la même conviction de
manière à ce que si négociation n'est
pas productive il puisse y avoir prise
de responsabilité pauthe
parce que ma conviction c'est que
l'enjeu est moins l'octroi du statut de
salarié que l'octroi des droits et des
protections qui correspondent
j'étais un petit peu longue je crois que
c'est le coeur du message que je voulais
que je voulais partager avec vous donc
se résume en disant un gros sujet de
contribution au financement de notre
système de santé a posé sans doute parce
à l'extension éventuelle de manière à
atténuer les risques de concurrence
déloyale pour l'extension à d'autres
domaines qui sont en gros les aides aux
entreprises des aides à la personne
et puis par ailleurs s'agissant de ces
de ces travailleurs la jouer à fond
pardonnez moi cette expression familière
la carte de la négociation collective
sur toutes les plateformes consciente de
ce qui s'y passe ont quand même beaucoup
évolué entre les premiers échanges qui
doivent élire cinq ans et puis dernier
18 avec les grands patrons je peux vous
dire que les choses ont beaucoup évolué
et je veux quoi faire une espèce de
convergence pour faire de la france une
réponse spécifique c'est vrai par
rapport à d'autres pays européens qui
consistera à ne pas vouloir adapter ce
qu'on appelle le tiers statut que tous
les partenaires sociaux refusent un tir
statut pour couvrir ces situations de
salarié particulier parce que je le dis
que ce serait une brèche qu'il serait
porteuse de beaucoup de déséquilibre y
compris dans un contexte libéralisation
mais en même temps de répondre à ce défi
si tu es dedans alors désolé sans
syndical commence qu'ils abordent le
sujet d'abord elles sont différents
comprennent certaines considèrent
qu'elles ont quand même la légitimité de
représenter le travail salarié qui ne se
sentent pas directement situation de
représenter ces travailleurs là même si
elles sont tout à fait tout j'allais
dire assez solidaires pour pas dire plus
de la situation de ces travail
un certain nombre d'entre elles
réfléchissent à des formes
d'organisation nouvelle parce qu'elle
estime que les attentes de ces
travailleurs leur relation temps de
travail l'autonomie dont il souhaite
conserver le bénéfice des points
importants tout ça il faut pas qu une
fois j'ai passé des heures
nous avons passé pardonnez-moi des
heures de concertation avec ses
représentants et donc une certaine
autonomie liberté d'organisation qui
n'enlève rien à la dépendance économique
je lui dirai plus monde est bien
d'accord je pense que c'était assez
clair sur ce point
leur font penser une projection pure et
simple y compris dans le mode de
fonctionnement de salariés des
négociations de branches des conventions
collectives serait tellement décalée de
la réalité que ce n'est pas pertinent et
certaines d'entre elles justement en vue
des prochaines élections s'appuie sur
des associations dans lesquelles qui
serait évidemment qu'ils accueilleraient
des travailleurs qui représente
évidemment cette activité qui l'ont
pratiqué plutôt que de projeter de la
représentation entre guillemets 1 de
salariés dans ces organisations là on
peut signaler le travail important que
fait par exemple une organisation comme
la cgt et auprès des livreurs pour
croiser justement créé des collectifs de
livreurs mais qui sont assis sur une
représentation cgt en province notamment
voilà la cbt aussi s'est engagé il faut
hésitent encore un petit peu mais voilà
globalement ils sont tous dans cette
réflexion sur comment intégrer et
respecter cette spécificité
ces travailleurs là tout en les
représentant il ya les accompagnant dans
son chemin j'avais dire de
représentation je crois moi très
sincèrement que nous avons prévu que
pouvait se présenter soit des collectifs
de ses travailleurs
nous avons rencontré également ils sont
des associations qui sont nés est dédiée
à cette activité là certaines d'entre
elles sont connues et à juste titre
parce que je voudrais dire devant vous
que même si parfois une exposition
présente brûle de très directe qui
traduit à la fois le côté très récent de
cette dialogue social mais aussi
l'engagement qui est celle de ses
premiers militants que j'ai un grand
respect pour ces collectifs de
travailleurs mais aussi encore une fois
ils ont une vision du dialogue social
qui ne repose pas sur une pratique de
nombreuses années on a vu des
organisations syndicales moi je crois
beaucoup à des logiques de rapprochement
entre pas de fusions et de
rapprochements qui permettent aux
organisations traditionnelles
traditionnel d'appuyer des nouveaux
acteurs dans leur professionnalisation
et ce n'est pas péjoratif pour moi dans
la structuration de leur fonctionnement
pour pouvoir encore une fois développé
ce dialogue social donc moi je suis au
total assez confiant même si évidemment
aujourd'hui le vrai sujet c'est celui
que vous avez évoqué monsieur rapporteur
c'est que quand on discute on sent bien
que la grande majorité des livreurs la
grande majorité des vtc même s'ils sont
évidemment tout à fait consciente d'être
en situation inacceptable
so loin
est en situation de prise en compte de
l'intérêt d'une organisation collective
pour représenter leurs droits donc la
participation par exemple à ce futur
scrutin est un état défi absolument
redoutable qui est devant nous c'est
vrai qu'à l'autre bout du spectre en
parle d'indépendance je voulais répondre
à votre question sur comment on explique
la polarisation en réalité une
polarisation qui est très clair ce
statut d'indépendant il est soit très
élevé avec des experts de haut niveau
qui quitte l'entreprise qui peuvent
parfaitement assimilé statut
d'indépendant ils sont dans une relation
d'équilibrer la valeur de leur expertise
avec des entreprises je vais vous dire
que le grand mouvement du belize à sion
qui n'est pas encore vu c'est que
l'entreprise de plus en plus va devoir
faire fonctionner et renoncer à la
prétention d'avoir toute la compétence
dont on a besoin à l'intérieur de ces
emplois donc je vois bien un phénomène
pour donner moins on sait pas forcément
péjoratif du père isation vers le haut
en ce sens que les entreprises ont de
plus en plus sa voix rappelle pas de la
compétence externe de très haut niveau
très qualifiés qui aura un statut
d'indépendant mais entre nous qui ne
pose pas de problème de représentation
de contribution de cotisation que
sais-je encore mais qui devra pouvoir
s'appuyer sur ses formes là parce que
excusez moi je passe d'un sujet à
l'autre mais l'obsolescence des
compétences avant une envie nantes une
compétence en entreprise elles
deviennent obsolètes
après 8 à 10 en tout cas c'est ce que
j'ai connu quand je commençais à ce
métier de drh aujourd'hui l'obsolescence
de compétences par exemple dans le
domaine si important d'informatique du
numérique pas se joue entre 18 et 24
mois donc on voit bien que la capacité
pour une entreprise d'avoir sous forme
de salariés de cdi en permanence tous
les niveaux de compétences à l'intérêt
entreprises disponibles est un pari qui
plus que difficile à imaginer
et donc je voulais le signaler en
passant par ce que il ya une
libéralisation par le haut à travers l'
expertise de haut niveau n'assistons pas
qui est très problématique
potentiellement pour l'emploi très
qualifiés je le dis aussi vers l'actuel
évidemment des jeunes vont s'orienter à
l'issue du parcours qui va être encore
une fois un mode d'organisation du
travail habituel et puis il ya l'emploi
peu qualifié massivement qui a commencé
encore une fois dans les plateformes
dites de mobilité mais qui va s'étendre
progressivement et donc il faut vraiment
veiller à l'impact sur l'emploi parce
que je crois que je vais terminer je
crois que de plus en plus et là encore
les en personnel mais quand je vois je
viens de rentrer de rendre deux
importantes missions pour la fédération
bancaire française sur les conséquences
des nouvelles de l'intelligence
artificielle de l'automatisation des
process etc sur l'emploi cette fois-ci
de qualifier alors pas forcément de très
haut niveau mais sur l'emploi qualifié
quand je projette l'évolution de métier
de comptable de ma j'avais beaucoup râlé
à l'époque façade et mckinsey et
d'autres cabinets anglo-saxons qui
n'hésitait pas duo a projeté la
disparition de 47 % des emplois 10 ans
ils ont fait beaucoup de mal ils ont
fait très peur
donc je suis très critique selon regards
mais à l inverse aujourd'hui avec le
regard du praticien quand il faut il pas
du théoricien je suis quand je vois la
rapidité avec laquelle ces plates formes
d'intelligence artificielle c'est
technologique 10 du diplôme ning
pardonnez-moi d'automatisation se
développe
je dis évidemment que la question
centrale il ne faudrait pas pour des
choses autrement que ce débat sur les
plates formes de mobilité sur les baies
risation de passes perd de vue c'est que
le grand défi social
le grand défi d'adaptation de notre
modèle yeah yeah l'emploi demain où
j'allais dire une main d'oeuvre y
compris main d'oeuvre qualifiée et
comment j'accompagne les gentils 6
émouvant parce que ma conviction en
inverse c'est que quand les entreprises
rendant c'est logique d'anticipation de
ces transformations correspond montée en
qualification de l'incompétence des
comptables et contrôleurs de gestion les
experts etc
pour accompagner ce mouvement on voit ce
moment là qu'on repositionne des
collaborateurs sur la gestion
prévisionnelle des emplois
astucieux dont s'appuient sur des
départs pour éviter la casse sociale
associée à des ajustements trop brutaux
donc je vois bien le grand défi qui est
aussi derrière ce qu'on appelle parfois
utilisation et ça pousse un terme
impropre alors promis de parler de
transformation numérique du travail de
monter en compétences et y compris pour
les emplois à valeur ajoutée on ne peut
pas dire d'emploi de cadres ou d'experts
de haut niveau
on voit bien qu'on a un très grand défi
qu'il ne faut pas perdre de vue parce
que ils supposent des adaptations des
habitations qui prendront du tournage et
un peu brouillon ensuite anciens
s'essayer découvrir quelques-unes des
thématiques que vous avez évoquées dans
un laps de temps que je sais limitée
voilà madame la présidente
oui merci beaucoup monsieur mak ling
j'aimerais savoir si vous savez où en
est le plan du gouvernement c'est pour
les indépendants il devait faire suite
au rapport points finalement les
propositions avancées notamment de
couverture sociale via les entreprises
de portage salarial ne convenait pas à
une partie des travailleurs des
plateformes
est-ce que alors bien sûr il ya le
travail qui est fait au niveau européen
vous avez parlé auquel participent et
pour lequel vous êtes force de
proposition en tout cas pour notre part
notre pays
mais qu'en est il donc de ce plan tout
de même annoncé par alain griset à
différentes reprises d'assez ces
derniers mois pour les indépendants est
ce que vous savez si quelque chose va
réellement sorti ou est ce que c'est la
directive européenne qui prendra le
dessus
écoutez deux choses d'abord les
collectifs de travailleurs nous ont
exprimé leur refus par les collectifs
des travailleurs nous ont exprimé leur
refus de voir la protection sociale dans
le champ du dialogue social
c'était un peu marre pas surprise pour
pas dire plus ils ont dit non non dès
lors qu'on a un statut d'indépendant si
on n'est pas salarié on ne voit pas
pourquoi les plateformes avec lesquelles
il a déjà beaucoup de dépendances
on deviendra dépendant aussi des
plateformes pour le choix de notre
protection sociale
si on est indépendant ça relève j'allais
dire du régime des indépendants sa
relève évidemment de dispositifs nous ne
souhaitons pas que les plateformes
détermine pour nous dès lors qu'on est
considéré comme indépendant
le type de couverture sociale de
complémentaires santé dont on peut avoir
besoin de ça je le dis parce que la
protection sociale et sans doute avec le
revenu minimum les temps de repos et la
transparence des algorithmes l'unmis
grandes thématiques sur lesquelles il
faut protéger il faut progresser
rapidement
donc le projet de loi griset à pour le
comme ça si vous voulez en tout cas
l'idée que l'on légifère sur
l'amélioration de la protection sociale
des indépendants et le cas échéant
venir parce que moi je suis profondément
convaincu sur le financement cette
protection sociale avec les nouveaux
acteurs économiques parce que je pense
qu'il ya un déséquilibre lac en train de
se créer qui est problématique nous ne
cachons pas mais je le dirai plus je
pense très sincèrement que ce projet
doit être absolument nécessaire parce
que c'est lui qui peut faire émerger une
amélioration de la situation qui
progressivement a déjà été connu
quelques évolutions mais qui permettrait
de beaucoup mieux couvrir les
indépendants et parmi les indépendants
les plus fragiles d'entre eux grâce à un
dispositif amélioré donc là dessus je
crois qu'il ya une vraie attente j'ai
cru comprendre que ce projet de loi
était toujours en préparation mais en
tout cas si je devais décrire le schéma
qui permettra à notre pays de progresser
je leur ai zimeray en dix ans est un
schéma qui verraient dans cette régie
stature aboutir un dispositif de
protection sociale complémentaire des
indépendants tournée notamment vers les
plus fragiles d'entre eux un dispositif
qui permettrait l'organisation et la
structuration des représentants des
travailleurs de ces battements pour
qu'il puisse y avoir négociations avec
accor généralisable à l'ensemble des
travailleurs des plateformes dans le
cadre de cette mandature
je crois que si on avait progressé sur
ces deux éléments là nonobstant le débat
encore une fois légitime qu'il ya
quelques quelques enjeux que j'ai essayé
d'évoquer du salariat on aurait fait
progresser la situation de ces
travailleurs
voilà ça c'est mes deux convictions donc
pour rejoindre votre préoccupation
madame la présidente c'est très
important que l'on progresse rapidement
sur ce volet de la protection sociale
qui ne passe pas par la négociation
sociale entre les plateformes et les
travailleurs des plateformes et qui
passe bien par des dispositifs
j'allais dire qui permettront
d'améliorer dispositifs d'ordre
législatif qui permettront d'améliorer
la protection sociale et son financement
des travailleurs indépendants très bien
je vous remercie
je crois que notre collègue michel
canevet souhaite poser une question donc
je lui donnais pas vrai merci madame la
présidente
oui dans le prolongement de ce qui vient
d'être évoquée à l'instant on nous dit
que ordinairement l'ensemble des
travailleurs des plateformes préfère
plutôt effectivement le statut
d'indépendant que le ca du salariat
hormis un certain nombre d'initiatives
qui ont été initiés devant les tribunaux
est ce que vous confirmez effectivement
que c'est plutôt la préhension globale
et conséquemment il faut sans doute
travailler effectivement comme vous
venez d'évoquer sur la question du
statut d indépendant et voir quelles
sont les améliorations globales que l'on
peut apporter au statut d âprement les
indépendants qui pourraient
effectivement répondre dans ce cas au
cadre social dans lequel pourrait
évoluer l'ensemble de ces travailleurs
c'est un premier sujet et puis un
deuxième je voulais revenir sur la
question de pascal savoldelli tout à
l'heure sur les secteurs concernés
le vin peut évoquer les métiers
financiers effectivement parmi les
secteurs susceptibles d'être concernés
par ces nouvelles formes de travail en
complément de ceux qui sont identifiés
or sur les livreurs et les chauffeurs
vtc ce qui en a d'autres est ce que vous
voyez deux grandes tendances qui
commence à se dégager
dès à présent et sur lequel il
conviendra de se pencher assez
rapidement parce que l'ampleur des
personnes concernées et ce que tu fais
en sorte que ce sujet aussi comme ce fut
le cas pour les deux catégories que je
viens d'évoquer sur votre première
question monsieur sénateur très
clairement mais encore une fois j'ai le
sentiment que
d'ailleurs il ya la cour de cassation a
rendu un arrêt important en france on
n'a pas vu derrière cette part est
important même si encore une fois et
c'est heureux des cabinets ont structuré
des actions collectives des collectifs
sont organisés on n'a pas vu derrière
cet arrêt je le dis a spontanément des
milliers de livres heure où des milliers
de vtc parce que je pense sincèrement
que beaucoup d'entre eux souhaiteraient
pouvoir continuer à exercer dans le cas
d'une activité d'indépendant où il
décide ou pas d'aller travailler ou line
up to pas pour telle plateforme et
voyez-vous - le drh que je suis reste
profondément interpellé je reviens sur
ce point la cour de cassation a
considéré qu'il y avait mises en
situation de subordination dans le laps
de temps qui faisait la course est
incontestable mais à l inverse le vieux
drh que je suis se dire qu'un salarié à
tout moment de la journée peut arbitrer
entre vous et votre compétiteurs par
rapport au principe de loyauté qui
lui-même à des contreparties
je dis tranquillement que si on aller
dans cette voie c'est pas sans
contrepartie je quitte ce n'était pas
vraiment la réponse à votre question
mais je voulais compléter quelque chose
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure parce que
c'est trop facile de poser le salariat
qui à mon avis le levier qui permet de
répondre à une situation de déséquilibre
inacceptable en réponse universelle qui
permettrait d'ouvrir ce n'est pas dans
les bras dans les équilibres important
des droits des devoirs je considère que
pouvoir choisir entre vous et votre
concurrent à tout moment ce n'est pas
compatible avec le statut de salarié
choisir son temps de travail qui est une
liberté importante mais aussi
économiquement elle tellement près
dictée dans un centre de calcul est
relative
il n'empêche que rentrer dans des
horaires stricts précis définis ce n'est
pas tout à fait ce à quoi aspire la
majorité donc je crois vraiment que la
réponse est de dire le salariat et le
recours utilisé dans des situations pour
faire progresser le niveau de protection
et je crois que si on trouve une réponse
en france par rapport au risque encore
une fois que j'évoque au départ c'est
pour moi la voix alors d'avoir
privilégié alors d'ailleurs même les
collectifs les plus engagés qui
utilisent le salariat comme levier de
pression
faute d'un dialogue social organisé ne
vous disent pas et j'ai rencontré à dire
des cabinets d'avocats spécialisés ne
vous disent pas nous revendiquons le
statut de salarié pour tous obligatoire
parce qu'ils l'ont bien compris
c'est parfaitement vrai pour les bêtes
ca y compris pour les livreurs mais à l
inverse il souhaite pour aller jusqu'au
bout de ce qu'ils décrivent que l'option
puisse est offerte
c'est vrai ce qui pose quelques
questions je voulais revenir sur un
exemple est souvent cité qui est
l'exemple de just hits pardonnez moi
c'est le nom de la plateforme
justin a décidé d'opter pour ce statut
de salarié on a écouté just hits
interrogé ce jeu c'est extrêmement
intéressant et ça ne leur avaient rien
aux mérites qu'il ya puisque par
définition ce sont des disruption il
introduit ces plateformes et bien qu'il
soit discuté sur leur mode de
fonctionnement par d'autres plateformes
après tout c'est la règle du jeu mais
quand on a interrogé de ce titre il ya
deux trois points qui nous ont
extrêmement intéressé la première
suggestif vous le savez c'est une
plateforme qui ne fait qu il ne vit que
marginalement j'avais dire de l'activité
de livraison et principale elle met en
relation directe et restaurateurs et les
clients donc elle n'a pas la même
sensibilité dans son modèle économique à
d'autres plateformes puisque en gros ça
représente entre 20 et 30% de sens il va
faire l'essentiel venant et à la berce
on peut très bien imaginer que quand
votre chiffre d'affaires provient pour
70% de la qualité de la relation entre
restaurateurs des mises en relation
directe vous pouvez avoir un intérêt à
avoir un statut qualifié du coup attiré
les meilleurs livreur moi ça me va bien
parce que ça c'est une progression de la
situation par le haut si je puis dire
dans le cadre d'une alternative qui
permettrait d'aboutir mais par contre de
complément qui sont importants le
premier c'est le taux de démission de
livreurs il avait rejoint justin
justement pour accéder à ce statut
salarié présenté comme assure un haut
lieu minimum mais qui par rapport aux
contraintes du statut de salarié
démissionne assez rapidement et puis
deuxième élément c'est que je cite
évidemment met en place un dispositif de
sélection
parce que quand vous êtes engagé
contractuellement de manière plus fort
vous êtes plus exigeants sur la qualité
de la prestation dont je souhaite pour
le mesure bien les conséquences par
rapport à l'accès à l'accès j'allais
dire de travailleurs des six jeunes
souvent exclues du marché du travail à
l'emploi dont jeudi just hits est
heureux parce qu'il pousse le modèle
vers le haut c'est compatible son modèle
économique et donc je m'en félicite
parce que du coup ça peut conduire y
compris en matière d' indépendants
améliorer la situation délivrant pour
résister à cette compétition par le haut
si je puis dire sur plein de vie sociale
mais à linverse ne prétendons pas que de
ce titre c'est une réponse universelle
applicable est généralisable à
l'ensemble des plateformes c'est pour ça
que
voilà moi je crois qu'il faut remporter
sur un chemin principal la négociation
collective les accords pour faire
progresser rapidement la situation dès
l'année prochaine
j'ai senti beaucoup d'impatience
mais à l inverse que ce soit à travers
des mesures vraiment alsw à travers la
requalification et bien un dispositif
qui incite évidemment ce progrès social
à 6 évolution épicier à l'intérieur de
sayad et nouveau modèle économique
pertinent de salariés qui voient le jour
il faut bien les décortiquer mais tant
mieux ça ne veut pas dire que ces
modèles doivent s'imposer à l'ensemble
de l'économie des plateformes
ça c'était votre j'ai répondu aux deux
j'en ai oublié unes les autres secteurs
par des morts-vivants surtout pas
laisser entendre que les services
financiers pour moi c'est plutôt la
logique de la disruption numérique et
des emplois ce n'était pas tant comme
représentatifs des secteurs des
plateformes numériques sur les
plateformes numériques soyons clairs il
ya deux grands enjeux aujourd'hui et les
services à l'entreprise et les services
à la personne
sur ces deux domaines là s'agissant des
emplois peu qualifiés encore une fois
c'est là qu'on voit de plus en plus de
structuration d'une offre d'indépendants
alors qu'yvon si je vais vers la
qualification depuis des traducteurs qui
vous font qu'on peut recruter sur la
plateforme en quelques minutes jusqu'à
des emplois s'est qualifiée du côté de
la nouvelle économie qui peuvent être
regroupées dans les services à
l'entreprise donc ça couvre un spectre
de plus en plus large
et puis sur les services à la personne
on voit bien que tout ce qui est par
exemple un peu qualifiés ou à l' on voit
bien que se mettre en place des
plateformes qui vous fournissent
immédiatement un restaurant un cuisinier
de remplacement quand vous avez votre
cuistot dans un restaurant qui s'est
déclarée souffrent le matin quelques
heures après quelques minutes après vous
pouvez avoir bien les plateformes
numériques
une offre qui se proposent et tout autre
service de livraison qui ne sont pas de
livraison de repas voilà mais toutes les
services de livraison aux entreprises en
général donc voilà pour moi c'est toutes
les activités peu qualifiés tourné vers
la personne tourner dans l'entreprise
qui peuvent voir proposer des solutions
numériques
donc le grand défi pour moi y'a tout ce
que j'ai dit sur les conditions de
développement de cette activité je ne
reviens pas pu aussi le défi pour le
secteur traditionnel
et son offre si je prends l'exemple de
l'intérim on a reçu la terrine qui
encore une fois extrêmement mobilisés
avec des porte paroles très puissant 1
et on comprend aussi un enjeu direct
pour eux voilà si je prends le secteur
de l'intérim c'est important de voir
émerger dans les offres des personnes
qui vont répondre à la demande d'un
restaurateur qui a découvert le matin
son collaborateur était souffrant qui a
besoin non pas de formaliser dans un
contrat de travail écrit terrain mais
via un outil numérique un contrat de
deux heures de trois heures d'une demi
journée via évidemment le statut de
salarié
comment son intérêt mais il faut que ça
prenne quelques minutes ch faut pas dire
peu avec un petit test pour pouvoir
répondre à son besoin sinon s'ils
n'adaptent pas leur mode de
fonctionnement et notamment une double
pas ces outils numériques un nul doute
qu'entre la plateforme qui vous
proposera en quelques minutes et
quelques clics travailleurs qui
accessoirement encore une fois
n'appliquera pas forcément les mêmes
charges sociales
et puis la terrine où il ya la
formalisation d'un contrat préalable à
l'arrivée je force le trait déjà
l'intérim s'est modernisé mais il faut
vraiment qu'on retrouve un niveau de
souplesse dans la et là je parle pas
d'adaptation du droit social je dis
simplement dans le mode de
fonctionnement des économies
traditionnelles pour répondre mais je
vois bien services à la personne
services à l'entreprise emplois peu
qualifiés là pour le coup il ya des
enjeux très importants
très bien
si pour ces précisions y at il d'autres
collègues qui souhaitent poser des
questions mange en visio oui oui
d'abord il ya un document vous avez fait
un chemin de vigne d'un avis de
l'autorité de concurrence l'a comblé
savoir si c'était à l'échelle nationale
européenne rapidement sur cetet
l'échéance était ce n'est pas un avis et
c'est bien travailler faire projet de
directive qui existe et nous on a eu un
échange ramener officiel avec la
pancarte de nos travaux avec la
commission la direction de la
concurrence de la commission européenne
c'est bien européen ce n'est pas
national c'était européen la vidéo de
call of alors il ya deux niveaux ya une
grande consultation est organisée par
ailleurs et qui couvre l'ensemble du
statut de travailleur numérique avec je
crois parlementaire française très
impliqué un dans cette es activity
schiste est en contact mais elle elle
relaie un petit peu au niveau européen
les débats qui sont les autres d'une
autre aux niveaux national et puis il ya
par ailleurs une directive très précises
il vise à lady la situation d' accord
résulte pas d'une négociation pour
qu'ils ne soient plus qualifiés d'
entendre voilà jeudi à deux démarches au
niveau européen
la première que vous évoquez pendant
semble plus dépenser une grande
concertation au niveau de l'ensemble de
l'europe sur le statut et sur les enjeux
des celle dont je parlais qui est très
urgente c'est de pardonner masque de
lever espèce d'épée de damoclès qui est
au dessus de tout accord collectif
sans ce secteur qui serait considéré
comme une atteinte dans la concurrence
par n'importe quelle petite plateforme
qui fera un recours ne pas se voir
appliquer vous avez évoqué aussi la
question de nos entreprises qui seraient
amenés à utiliser par l'externalisation
c'est un sujet extrêmement important
tu oses été attentivement vous parler
par exemple traduction linguistique et c
est à dire pour moi il n'y a rien de
nouveau
l'entreprise certes avec la
mondialisation je pense qu'elle est
phénomène nouveau mais il ya déjà dans
les acteurs économiques dans les
entreprises des gens qui sont dotés
évidemment à la périphérie rôle
externalisant des missions donc j'avoue
que j'aimerais
on essaye d'approfondir le sujet ça veut
dire quoi
parce que par exemple
est ce que c'est pour baisser le coût du
travail il faut se parler aussi avec la
même franchise
est-ce qu'on soulève pas des
contradictions vous avez évoqué les
restaurateurs moi j'ai un problème avec
l'état
kitchen est ce que les davidson on a vu
fleurir la dans la dernière période
est-ce qu'elle amène une une réforme une
une mutation d'évolution positive des
métiers de la restauration
moi je n'en suis pas convaincu je pense
que vous n'auriez pas non plus oui mais
c'est une vraie question parce que c'est
des coûts de sortie de moins de 30%
monsieur donc vous voyez là il ya un
problème de compétitivité de concurrence
quand même et professionnalisation aussi
donc c'est pour vous dire que cet aspect
là que vous avez traité
moi je le vois un peu plus plus de
manières dialectique tôt que deux
manières de manière uniforme la dernière
chose et là vous dire que moi ce qui m'a
frappé donc ce n'est pas du tout une
analyse un c'est que la confusion qui
existe entre la notion d'autonomie et
d'indépendance du point de vue des
travailleurs des plateformes numériques
de travail où il ya une réelle confusion
franchement entre indépendance et
autonomie et c'est un sujet que j'ai
traité sur le terrain va y avoir des
rencontres est question peut-être je dis
ça mais ça c'est pas une question c'est
que j'ai trouvé dans ces évolutions dans
ce bouleversement la nature du travail
et des relations dans le travail
un isolement je n'ai jamais connu c'est
à dire voyez des certaines secteurs
c'est plus des hommes que des femmes ça
peut être des femmes aussi puisque vous
savez il ya le travail invisible c'est à
dire le travail domestique l'aide à
domicile tu es moins visible que
l'ivoire au chauffeur il ya il ya un
isolement
une cette solitude d'invisibilité qui à
mon avis ça a des conséquences ouailles
et sur la façon de s'organiser de
revendiquer de discuter de travail et de
aimer ce qu'on fait mais ça c'est pas
une question c'était un ressenti du vais
partager avec les bandes de la mission
l'âme la présidente et pino notre invité
non sur votre
sur votre premier point le fait que les
entreprises aient recours à des
contributions externes vous avez raison
est très ancien mais je voudrais prendre
un exemple très concret pour illustrer
l'évolution de la situation c'est la
facilité d'accès et profondeur de
l'offre c'est-à-dire qui rend évidemment
qui vient accentuer changer les choses
quand j'ai commencé à travailler en
entreprise dans des entreprises
internationales pour une grande
entreprise vérité assez courant d'avoir
des équipes de traduction assez c'est
assez correctement organisées
aujourd'hui les entreprises vont alors
systématiquement quand y'a un texte un
peu pointu j'avais dis bien développé
évidemment mais comme vous avez un test
sur lesquels vous êtes un peu exigeants
sur la qualité de la traduction vous
allez évidemment aller chercher sur une
plateforme à traduire et c'est pas en
soi un problème je suis je suis assez
d'accord et vous m
c'est la facilité d'accès de l'offre
langue ça devient un sujet c'est ce que
j'essayais de dire mais trop rapidement
c'est quand c'est propre rejoint
l'obsolescence accélérée des compétences
et que du coup l'accès à des éléments
absolument clé du côté du numérique de
l'organisme ne se fait plus à travers ça
veut dire l'intégration dans
l'entreprise
de tels profils mais leur rareté parfois
leur coût la rapidité avec laquelle
encore une fois la compétence pays où
les vous conduit assez naturellement à
exclure du champ d'entreprise le recours
à ces contributions pour vous appuyer
et cela ça va assez loin et ça c'est
nouveau et en soit encore une fois ce
n'est pas forcément porteur de graves
déséquilibres d'atteinte c'est
simplement le constat que le statut de
salarié france n'a plus vocation à
accueillir forcément le coeur de la
compétence y compris en eau si je puis
dire par rapport à des nouvelles
organisations parce que les gens qui
sont déjà des jeunes qui sont derrière
ces expertises au très haut niveau ils
peuvent trouver aussi un certain intérêt
à cette diversité de situations
d'organisation etc
c'est simplement pour compléter un peu
le panorama sur libéralisation de
l'économie ces manifestations y compris
sur des fonctions à très haute valeur
ajoutée c'était une expression que vous
aviez que vous aviez employés dont je
crois qu'il faut il faut prendre acte
que quelque part ça fait partie des
éléments étrangers mais qu'il est
important que le secteur de l'entreprise
définissent du coup ça fait partie à mon
avis des éléments du nouveau contrat
social ou du futur contrat social
définissent le champ de ce qu'ils
estiment être des comptes
pense clé qui pour des raisons j'avais
dit royer ont rejoint ce que je disais
tout à l'heure sur ce statut de salarié
pour des raisons j'allais dire on est au
coeur du savoir faire de l'entreprise on
est au coeur de ma valeur ajoutée de ce
qui va faire la différence donc sage
internalise parce que je souhaite
fidéliser et investir dans la durée sur
ses compétences depuis d'autres
compétences et un drh demain je choque
beaucoup quand je dis ça mais c'est la
conviction du vieux des races aux
cheveux blancs que je suis un drh demain
on lui demandera presqu'autant de gérer
un portefeuille de compétences qui pour
certaines seront dans l'entreprise pour
certains seront à l'extérieur mais dis
donc assurer la disponibilité
l'entreprise que de gérer j'allais dire
un certain nombre de coureurs je me
projette peut-être à cinq ans ou à
septembre je crois que c'est pour un
petit peu de caractériser cette
évolution et je ne dis pas qu'elle est
souhaitable jeudi c'était quelque chose
vers lequel on est sisi blida les alors
a pas de collectif savez j'ai eu des
mots tellement comment dirais-je direct
que je ne peux pas les reprendre ici
mais j'ai été un des premiers
observateurs expert social à dire que le
tout télétravail était une bêtise d'un
termes plus directs légèrement pris dans
l'express
je crois profondément à la dimension
collective je crois au risque
d'isolement des télétravailleurs
je crois à cette nouvelle façon de
travailler en mode hybride je crois à la
représentation de leurs intérêts par les
organisations syndicales qui ne se
combine pas bien avec le télétravail et
les éléments à distance sur toutes les
conditions d'accès de ces organisations
disent outil ne favorise pas les
échanges
donc je pense que l'entreprise de
l'année bien au delà du sujet de
libéralisation ont négocié la
transformation des mairies du travail
l'entreprise doit conduire des
réflexions approfondies et c'est ce
qu'on fait dans beaucoup d'entre elles
et qu'on accompagne aujourd'hui dans le
cadre de la structure que j'anime mais
l'entreprise doit impérativement
réfléchir à ce qu'on appelle le travail
hybride en tout cas c'est une nouvelle
façon de travailler qui ne peut pas
passer par le clip télé travail parce
que la dimension collective qui est
source de performance et de productivité
je le dis aussi on cite souvent la
productivité elle a une dimension
collective des packs individuel le jeune
qui ont mettre pied à l'étrier le
partage en équipe qui peut en dégager
des solutions etc
voilà tout ça se construit dans le
collectif et ce collectif la vie quand
même mieux le présentiel que le tout
mêlé travaille pas je vais pas de plus
l'ombre je crois beaucoup parce que vous
avez dit sur la représentation du
collectif dans l'entreprise
oui très bien je crois que c'est
effectivement ce sont des points que
vous venez d'évoquer qui sont qui sont
importants et on voit bien aussi là que
la crise sanitaire les périodes de
confinement ont changé les pratiques
c'est ce que nous avons ce sur quoi nous
allons travailler sur la mission
d'information avec la délégation
d'entreprises et et tout est lié bien
sûr la volonté de nos jeunes de devoir
de nombreuses choses et à la fois d'être
en présentiel mais cette liberté de
pouvoir être sur plusieurs fronts en
même temps via est ce qu'il y à d'autres
questions non écoutez monsieur bruno
mettling vraiment un grand merci pour
votre intervention qui était très
intéressante
voilà mon commençons belle façon cette
mission d'information et nous attendons
également nous regarderons avec intérêt
la suite de vos travaux et bien sûr de
ceux du gouvernement
[Musique]